everybody is talking about the new m2
macbook air thermal throttling but of
course we expected that and we knew it
because we found that even the pro
thermal throttled under heavy load and
that one has a fan but what's different
about this video is that we are gonna
find out just how hot it gets we're
gonna look at the actual temperatures
how long it takes to get severe thermal
throttling what the frequencies are
doing and is there any cap is the actual
cpu slower than the version in the pro
and with that does this thermal
throttling issue really matter that much
should you actually worry about it well
let's go ahead and find out this right
here is the base model that a lot of
people are gonna buy it does have eight
gigs of ram 512 gigs of ssd and the
eight core gpu right out of the gate
we're idling at about 34 35 celsius now
this is the macbook that we did do a
full teardown on we're super careful
with it we reapplied thermal paste that
performs the same as apples and we did
get a note from an engineer saying that
the whole metal cover likely isn't a
vapor chamber but more of a metal
shielding with a sticker there because
these modern electronics are a lot more
sensitive than they used to be when
they're packed with so many different
chips with that i have to tell you about
our giveaway because we are giving away
one of these brand new m2 macbook airs
and i don't care where you are in the
world i will pay for the shipping and i
will pay for the import duties or taxes
all you have to do is one be subscribed
and two comment below on each one of our
launch week videos each time you comment
on a video that gives you an extra entry
to win and on monday july 25th we will
be randomly selecting a video on camera
so make sure you guys check out that
video as well and before we start
testing let's grab our thermal camera
and get a baseline of the temperatures
now take a look at that
this thing is running pretty dang cool
the hottest spot is actually on the
display at 33 degrees celsius and the
whole base now is just showing
a nice cool blue so it is very cool at
idle now the first thing that i want to
test is to see if there is any cap on
the wattage or the frequency with this
fanless design so i'm going to be
running geekbench 5 and i'm going to be
taking a look at the cpu frequency here
as well as the peak wattage now the
highest that i saw with the m2 macbook
pro was 3
316 megahertz and
23.78 watts so far it is hitting over 3
300 megahertz so apple did not cap it
thankfully and as far as the wattage we
just hit 24.6
watts
basically within margin of error or
difference with the m2 macbook pro and
the scores also look fantastic matching
up with the macbook pro so if you do
short bursty tasks like most people do
you are not going to have any issue
don't be worried but with that said what
if you do want to do some gaming some 3d
rendering you say xcode photoshop stuff
that keeps a bigger longer load on the
cpu and gpu and now let's put that full
100 cpu load on with cinebench now i'm
going to start our multi-core run just a
single run right here to see what
performance we get for just a short
render without that throttling test and
before we look at the frequencies
because that does use a little bit of
the cpu to run that program now right
out of the gate we're at 95 degrees
celsius right away 99 it's been what i
don't know 10 15 seconds we're at
101 103 right there i should probably
just wait till it caps
104
107.
all right it should stick 108 right
there now people said that we were
freaking out about it hitting 108 with
the macro pro because we were doing some
heavy ak rendering
but it looks like we're getting the same
exact temperature now it hit that in
what like half the run so this just
proves that this is the target
temperature that apple is capping at it
used to be 95 degrees celsius with the
intel max and then some of them would
hit 100 like the m1s now 108 is what
apple is comfortable for that ceiling
and that is above boiling temperature
that's crazy all right we have our score
and it is 8551
compared to our m2 macbook pro that
scored 8
600
that is a difference of only 1.7
which is a lot less than i expected
after we saw how fast it heated up and
how hot it got so for those of you out
there that are going to be typing
comments saying you did a tear down in
this machine you can't test that you're
messing up the thermals well look at
that that is actually pretty impressive
and it shows that everything's working
properly but with that said let's see
what happens when we have an extended
load and what happens with the
frequencies and our wattage i'm going to
start doing a single run right here and
let's take a look at what we get right
at the gate we're running at 3.204
megahertz which is just like the m2
macbook pro and we hit a peak wattage of
22.4
we're now at 103 degrees celsius the cpu
is still running at full blast all right
it's slowing down a little bit more now
we're almost at three gigahertz the
wattage is dropping uh down just under
18. so we got 8357
for that run right there so slower than
the previous run and i started it up
right away so we have a consistent load
and now we're running just under three
gigahertz running at about 16 and a half
watts now halfway through that second
run it dropped down to 2.6 gigahertz the
wattage dropped down as well in order to
cool itself down it didn't want to stay
at 108 bam
7891 for a second run that's dropping
quick wow it's running at 2.2 gigahertz
now and only 9 watts alright guys we are
on our fifth run and it looks like the
macbook just changed something up
instead of cooling down quickly and
ramping up all the way now it is
choosing to run cooler by lowering the
clock speed consistently we're running
at 2.5 gigahertz at about 10 watts or so
which is actually pretty impressive it's
a low wattage for that frequency
and we're going to get about 95 degrees
celsius 94 now so it looks like apple
will not let it run indefinitely at 108
which is why some people are getting
not that great performance doing longer
renders and comparing it to even the m1
macbook pro which we will be doing soon
73
30.
wow alright so that was our sixth run
and that is already slower than the m1
macbook air doing its first run which
that also does uh slow down but i don't
think as much as this one seven two nine
five it keeps getting slower and slower
so i have to keep testing it seven 7302
that is our last run so it looks like
the m2 macbook air loses up to 17
of its cpu performance after it settles
in and it started out at 3.2 gigahertz
and then ended up at 2.65
once it was heat soaked and started
running cooler but slower so yes this
does throttle more and it ends up being
slower than the m1 chip with proper
cooling like in the macbook pro now with
that said let's go ahead and take a look
at the temperatures now that we've been
running this for a while it looks like
we're at 46 47 degrees celsius that is
pretty dang hot hotter than most laptops
that we've seen it is starting to cool
down a little bit here
uh and most of the temperatures right
there it's right where the m2 chip is
we're not getting too much heat transfer
and that might also show that that whole
metal shield just like the engineer said
is not a vapor chamber system because
then it'd be more even across but that
is just more shielding now there is
actually one benefit with this you guys
saw that the score dropped by 17
but our power usage dropped by more than
half so that trade-off is actually
pretty impressive meaning that your
macbook air after it's gone through its
hot phase will run cooler than the
macbook pro yes it will have less
performance but it's also going to use
less than half the wattage for the cpu
meaning that helps out with battery life
if you're pushing your machine now if
you want to see us mod this macbook air
and add some thermal pads to transfer
that heat and to see if we can fix or
greatly improve this thermal issue
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button below and that notification bell
because we're going to be testing out
that video and it made a big difference
with the m1 macbook air and now let's go
ahead and talk about the graphics now
some people have tested the 10 core
graphics but this is the 8 core with the
base model let's see how much this new
thinner profile affects the thermal
performance let's go ahead and start our
3dmark wildlife extreme stress test this
is going to run for 20 minutes it's
going to put a full load on the gpu just
like if you're rendering and using the
graphics or your gaming right out of the
gate we are running at about 10 and a
half watts at almost 1400 megahertz for
the graphics now unfortunately we don't
have any software yet that can read the
gpu temperatures the closest thing we
have is our cpu
and that is of course on the same chip
it's not as hot and it is starting to
heat up after we've been running this
for a few loops and it looks like after
four minutes we are getting some
slowdowns uh for the gpu now running at
about a thousand three hundred and
thirty four megahertz and is going a
little bit lower as well so i presume
now the graphics is over a hundred
degrees and at the fifth run we're
nearing a thousand megahertz now and
that is quite disappointing i was hoping
that a core would fare better and
wouldn't throttle much but it looks like
it definitely does so this is that just
has me thinking if the acor's throttling
this much what about the 10 core we
might end up with very similar
performance just because of heat now we
will be doing a comparison to the
highest spec m2 macbook air as well with
16 gigs 512 and the 10 core gpu so you
guys can look forward to that video we
just hit
990 megahertz 989 right there so looks
like after about 10 or so minutes it
starts slowing down even more we're
using less than half the power that it
did initially
as far as the actual temperatures we're
not sure but they did definitely drop
from about 90 92 in the cpu to about 75
so once again after about that 10 minute
mark or so the macbook decides hey let's
just get slow as long as we can cool
down now part of that could be like i
mentioned about it just getting too hot
on the bottom for comfort there are
legal limits i believe it's about 50
degrees celsius uh right now we're
looking at about 43 i did check about
two minutes ago before it starts slowing
down under a thousand megahertz and it
was 47
so it was getting dangerously close to
the legal limit for surface temperature
which is why it's probably slowing down
this much so we're almost done with the
last run so it's been pretty much 20
minutes and it looks like the graphic
settles in at about
950 megahertz and about 5 watts or so so
that is pretty low now here we see all
of the runs we start out pretty strong
with the score 5611
and the few first few runs you're kind
of just losing a little bit of
performance not drastic and then when we
get to the fourth run is when it starts
taking a dive and that pretty much shows
that our system even though we took it
apart the heat spreader the thermal
paste everything's working properly
until it gets saturated and it just
falls off a cliff there after that
massive dive it does recover just a
little bit but then slowly starts
tapering down and it just continues that
trend so it looks like you can only rely
on getting the full graphics performance
for about four minutes which are these
first runs and then it gets drastically
lower our stability score ended up being
73.8 percent meaning that we got a 26.2
loss in graphics performance and this is
only the eight core model that makes me
even more interested to compare it to
the 10 core as well as the m1 macbook
airs graphics so now to answer the
question we had at the start should you
worry about this does it really matter
should people be freaking out well
what we found in our testing is that if
you're doing a cpu based task that
really hammers the cpu and it is a task
that is quicker than 10 minutes or so
especially in the first five minutes you
won't get too much slowing down after
about the 10 minute mark is where it
decides to really slow down to cool
itself down and as far as the graphics
if you're hammering the graphics for
example gaming or rendering with
graphics
then as long as it's quicker than five
minutes it's also not that terrible of a
performance
but if you're doing tasks that are
longer than that then you'll benefit
greatly from the macbook pro and with
that keep in mind that these are tasks
that are exclusive if you're doing
something that uses both for example
video editing with tougher footage that
maxes it out or maybe 3d rendering both
with cpu and graphics combined or other
tasks that time is going to get cut down
drastically my guess is about two or
three minutes until it's saturated
because you're hammering both of those
at the same time and we'll test some of
that in our macbook comparisons
you guys let me know your thoughts down
below did you think you're gonna get
this much throttling about 17 for the
cpu and then about 26 for the graphics
we want to hear your guys's opinions
click that circle above if you want to
see more videos like this one make sure
you comment down below for a chance to
win check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]